hello everyone uh every now and then i
do news on this channel i don't do it a
ton trying to do it slightly more often
because i do have fun with it but i try
not to do it
if i don't have anything else to add to
things
um
and i basically got asked about this
story a lot and just wanted to clarify
um maybe the pieces that people have
been missing so
if you missed it very controversially uh
it effectively came out that ubisoft was
completely decommissioning assassin's
creed liberation hd
even for people who had bought the game
meaning that even if you had purchased
this game you would no longer be able to
play it you wouldn't be able to download
it no access to dlc or online services
um after september 1st 2022
and the reason that people think this is
not unreasonable
uh it says down here notice at the
request of publisher assassin's creed
liberation hd is no longer available for
sale on steam which is especially messed
up uh because this was just after
um a
uh sale they had a 75 off sale
and then like days later
this comes out uh it otherwise says
notice please note that this title will
not be accessible following september
1st 2022 so yeah they literally go on
sale 75 off people buy it on sale and
then get told oh by the way you won't
even be able to access this thing that
you just gave us money for that we
clearly put on sale to try to make more
of you buy it after this date that is
terrible practice oh my gosh um
and they did
kind of announce some of this
ahead of time so this here let me
refresh the page move it over a little
bit
is
uh ubisoft posted this uh a number of
days ago a week ago about how they were
decommissioning online services in
september 2022 for several games it says
closing the online services for some
older games allows us to refocus our
resources on delivering great
experiences for players who are playing
newer or more popular titles to help us
achieve this a number of older titles
will be added to our list of
decommissioned online services on the
1st of september 2022 below you will
find a detailed breakdown for the
effects of this new round of
decommissions per platform so then it
has game name what platform they're on
and the changes to functionality so for
example assassin's creed 2 on pc and
playstation 3 you'll be unable to play
multiplayer link ubisoft accounts
in-game or use online features but you
can still play
assassin's creed too
which i guess like why would you really
want to now anyway when you can play the
updated versions
assassin's creed liberation the game in
question the pc
says you will be unable to link ubisoft
accounts in-game or use online features
additionally the installation and access
to dlc will be unavailable which also
seems really strange to me um it does
show up a few times that's there for
brotherhood that's there for assassin's
creed
three
drivers san francisco a lot of them far
cry 3 not being able to install dlc
that you've paid for
is not great but essentially there's
nothing on here on the listing for
assassin's creed liberation that would
indicate to me
that if you would purchase the game you
would never even be able to play offline
ever again
and
obviously that's at odds with the
screenshot from steam and also the other
games let me find a picture of another
one real quick here so this is from the
same person who kind of uh figured this
all out and shared it on twitter the at
is uh at nors3
um
so this is what i want to sell blacklist
which is also on this list of
decommissioned games looks like it says
notice dlc within this product as well
as online elements and features will
become unavailable though the base game
will remain accessible as of september
1st 2022 obviously very different to
what uh liberation initially said
sorry you've accidentally got some of my
premiere pro on the side of this from an
interview slash podcast it's just about
to go up with cliff blezinski my bad
um
yeah obviously this was different it
said please note that this title will
not be accessible following september
1st
2022
so they did update it
so it is back on steam at the original
price no longer even on sale
that's so funny um and now says notice
dlc for this product and online elements
and features will become unavailable as
of september 1st the base game will
continue to be playable i mean this
sucks anyway and i feel like the video
game industry is only getting worse and
worse
uh with
i'm forgetting the term but like
preservation video game preservation
it's like the industry just really
doesn't care about it and it's such a
shame that other people aren't allowed
to step in and pay for it in a lot of
cases there are a few organizations that
you can donate to um
who do their best to try to
you know act in the favors of video game
preservation but in a lot of cases like
they've even been legally prevented from
doing so it just it just really the
approach really bums me out so many of
these older games and liberation's not
even that old 2014 um that so many of
them
don't
they don't they just don't care they
don't care about their existence anymore
it just just sucks to lose
all the games um
but
ubisoft did send out an update here let
me move this across
move myself over here look at me go
so ubisoft sent out an update to press
saying
well we just read this is from ign
ubisoft sent the following statement
saying that current owners will still be
able to access play or re-download them
which would be what is reflected in the
decommission online services article
that they posted which i don't believe
has been edited
it says as stated in our support article
only dlcs and online features will be
affected by the upcoming decommissioning
still don't understand why dlcs
they don't want to storm on a server i
guess i don't
current owners of those games will still
be able to you to access play or
re-download them our teams are working
with our partners to update this
information across all storefronts and
are also assessing all available options
for players who will be impacted when
these games online services are
decommissioned on september 1st 2022. it
has always been our intention to do
everything in our power to allow those
legacy titles to remain available in the
best possible conditions for players
and this is what we are working towards
so
you've got a couple of options
for what actually happened to you and
the main thing is i wanted to talk about
this because it fully seems like um
norse 3
on twitter was the reason that people
found out about this obviously the
decommissioning news was public but i
don't think that that many people would
have been looking at the assassin's
creed liberation
steam page
um in order to find that actual wording
or even look hard enough to find that
wording and then he shared it um
and it blew up and they changed the
wording which is like okay great reason
to talk about this to make sure that
this doesn't happen to people because
this is so
anti-consumer
that if they had actually done what it
originally said on that steam page i
think that uh governments would come for
them i think that would be considered to
be illegal in numerous countries like
australia for example um
had a legal battle with steam regarding
australia's refund policies that steem
did not
abide by and it was changed so i would
think that doing this
taking product away from people who own
it would especially offline
would be completely illegal it's just
such a
unbelievably crappy thing to do to your
players to people who have supported
your company or bought the game
on sale recently because he advertised
it for sale
however
it's not what's happening
thankfully it either changed because of
the noise which again happy to
contribute to the noise to make sure
that they're like seeing it
but i feel like there are two things
that happened to you this was either a
mistake
which is what i'm inclined to believe
or
they were trying to pull a fast one so
it's either a mistake in that
somehow there was a miscommunication
with steam or valve
and
they accidentally pushed that that game
would not be available whatsoever for
some reason
even though their article does not list
it as having different terms
to any of the other games um
what they've said in this statement is
the same as what their oh my god the
pop-ups on this website
as what they said on the decommission
page so it's it could have been a
mistake that that one game particularly
i'm not sure if it happened to any
others got pushed that way
unless they edited that decommissioning
online services article but from
everything i could find everyone says
that they did not edit it i can't find a
previous version of it
so it was an accident somehow got
miscommunicated miscommunicated somebody
pressed the wrong button i don't know
how the back end of steam works for that
kind of stuff and how closely you have
to work with partners
option two
is that
they tried to do that on the f on the on
the sly without telling anybody that
that's what they were doing for
liberation specifically
and that again they didn't outline
outline it i'm so bad at words right now
in this decommissioning article
which is
so unbelievably shady that i think
that's unlikely
i just can't picture a company of this
scale doing that
um
but i don't know it's not like you
should necessarily trust the megacorps
i'm not really sure
it has to be one of those two options
it's either
they were trying to trick people and
gave out misinformation and were always
planning to de-list that game completely
or it was a mistake i don't know um of
course yeah it has been updated that is
no longer a thing and i did want to talk
about it to be like
good
please talk about this like please
players actually make noise about this
one this is an actual massive problem
there are things people yell about that
i don't think are problems this one
is so bad for consumers um bad for the
industry bad for the preservation of
video games we do not want this we want
to talk about it to let you know that we
do not want it and it's just especially
feels like such a red flag coming from a
company who you know got into nfts
recently and oh it sucks to see
other companies like square
talking about interest in nfts and um
it just seems like such a convenient way
to dump your old games that didn't
support any of that tech while pivoting
to becoming an nft web 3 company rather
than a video game publisher which i'm
sure is also some convenient way to get
around loot box gambling laws in some
countries as well if you re-brand
uh
to being an nft store or an online store
instead of being a video game it's just
a future that i hate i just i don't like
it i don't want it
i'm very much talking about stuff that
i'm not informed on now i have no idea
if that's true it's just it's just scary
i do not want anything to do with this
and thus wanted to talk about it but
yeah i'm in the camp of thinking this is
probably a mistake
um and i think if they were to lie about
it they could potentially get in legal
trouble and that's part of it
but wanted to issue the update to say
this is not happening you can still play
liberation hd thankfully and also if you
see this stuff talk about it if you see
something
say something
[Laughter]